[Musique]
mais ça va je crois que le premier jour
de tournage de saïd c'est également le
premier jour de tournage de la série et
c'est le premier jour de tournage de
laëtitia
on a tourné ses scènes dans une vraie
prison évidemment avec tout ce que ça
implique d'aller dans des entreprises
ont aussi en état d'esprit quoi tu vas
pas tourné en prison comme tu ton en
supermarché c'est pesant
ce qui déclenche
elle met sa voix la scène du parloir qui
est un moment très fort qui est un
moment aussi un peu douloureux a tourné
pour laetitia qui est un moment pas
forcément simple à tourner pour ça ils
n'ont plus
d'accès toi comme pas compris c'est moi
qu'on n'a pas encore fini avec toi
ici ou ailleurs c'est pareil pour moi je
pique [ __ ] ta [ __ ] de vie
et quand je vais sortir je vais
récupérer le petit
faire
ils s'en sont évidemment super bien
sortis tous les deux et je me rappelle
qu'avec david diane mon second
réalisateur on est rentré le soir en se
disant si c'est ça le niveau de notre
saison si aujourd'hui avec saïd et et
laetitia on a donné le ton de trouver la
saison on contient une grosse saison 2
[Musique]
dans les coulisses de la saison te de
valider
la deuxième saison de valider c'est un
an d'écriture
c'est trois mois et demi de tournage
c'est une quarantaine de comédiens
c'est une équipe d'une soixantaine de
personnes
plusieurs centaines de figurants dans
les cités
la scène de concert des scènes de soirée
ceux-ci mois de postproduction
c'est canal et c'est donc d'une neuf
fois trente minutes
à l'est
[Musique]
bon d'abord
ça a été un
grand débat avec moi même puis avec mes
équipes de savoir si
apache allait être dans cette saison 2
ou pas c'était un pari très risqué parce
que
des construire quelque chose qui
marchait aussi bien l'alchimie de ce
trio
c'est presque suicidaire un moment de se
dire cécile c'est super et bah alors on
arrête
je sais que des gens ont pris un choc
qui ont adoré la série en partie aussi
parce qu'il ya ce final qui est
incroyable
ya des gens qui n'ont pas compris qu'on
finisse comme ça il ya des gens qui ont
eu trop mal au coeur de se dire mais tu
vis tu viens de me faire aimer un mec
pendant cinq heures tumultueux à la fin
d'une balle dans la tête pas possible de
me faire sa première
quel kiff incroyable c'était pour moi de
voir sur les réseaux tous ces gens qui
étaient convaincus qu'apache n'était pas
mort qui était convaincu que la balle
finalement été sorti qui étaient
convaincus puisque c'était sur instagram
en fait c'était une vidéo pour le buzz
passez moi à dire aux gens non mais
apache est mort apache est mort s'il
vous plaît croyez nous non je vous crois
pas à soit possible parce que les gens
les métros
parfois les gens sur les raisons eu des
idées que j'aurais adoré avoir moi même
il ya un moment où j'ai eu des doutes en
me disant [ __ ] si saku marketing c'est
génial mais c'est vrai qu'en plus ça
aurait pu avec sur instagram que l'on
fait sur une vidéo enregistrée avant
qu'elle kiffe de provoquer ça dans la
tête du spectateur c'est quelque chose
que le cinéma ne te donne pas ça c'est
la série qui te donne
[Musique]
puis après quand tu sais que tu a
provoqué tout ça comment tu fais pour
qu'ils soient pas déçus parce que on a
tout fait pour que les gens aiment
apache et là on attaque une nouvelle
saison sans la page mais avec quand même
un peu deux apparitions
passer une bonne soirée bienvenue sur
skyrock pour ce planète rap exceptionnel
consacré à l'album totem album posthume
d'apache dans ce premier épisode la
première scène franck m'a dit écoute là
c'est encore une scène importante et
puis je vais demander aussi un peu de
voix là de dégager il faut dégager de
l'émotion parce que tata brave et saïd
où ils viennent et vient de rendre
hommage à leur poste vous êtes venus
pour nous faire une annonce importante
voilà comme tu sais pour nous c'est très
important que le nom d'un poste ne sont
jamais oubliés donc avec brahim on a eu
l'idée de lancer notre label en inde et
et il va s'appeler apache musique donc
on est là et tu te laisses aller tu te
laisses porter un petit peu par le
déroulé de cette scène
[Musique]
toute l'atmosphère est mise pour te puce
est vraiment s'y prendre et c'est
vraiment lourd c'est une scène très très
pesante contre menton surtout sa musique
le temps tirer tout être le petit zoom
sur le micro ma chance et des trucs très
très très poignant
voilà mon idée a très vite été de me
dire mais à tendance et mortelles sont
encore moins sur les photos il faut
qu'on joue l'héritage est l'héritage
c'est le création de leur label la
création d'appareils musique à
l'initiative brahim et saïdou en mémoire
d'apache maintenant faut comprendre
faire et voilà comment on perpétue et
c'est pour ça que je disais que dans
cette saison 2 un patch sera quand même
un peu avec nous parce qu'il est avec
nous tout le long
[Musique]
alors sur vraiment saison 2 le
personnage
il prend un peu en maturité t'en veux
pas de tension c'est un peu plus présent
peu plus intelligent mais ça reste là
toujours la
cgt parle de cannes gratuit mais bien
sûr gratuit gkn toutes sortes de meuf
j'ai un truc brahim les neuf ça veut
dire exemple
et c'est là qu'est la plus chère à
chaque pas cet outrage
bah ouais carrément sont en fait des
pillages étaient une bizarre dont je
suis pas tout je suis la meilleure amie
de l'alpha et et surtout surtout quand
on remonte à la ratatouille bas parce
que j'ai l'habitude de me faire ronfler
moi aussi et je sais qu'on a grâce à
fait dégonfler donc tu as un problème
parce que dans ta tante jeanne bogdanov
grave dans une love story jason life
stories de fou
j'étais sérieux toi je ressemble à une
quinzaine et ump chaud
mais je sais pas je pensais qu'il y
avait un truc que tu veux atteindre que
je me présente à bhl vois tu peux pas
les signaux quoi toi
et marc espalioux il est remonté sur
williams est ce qu on a kiffé chez les
personnages en saison une leur espèce de
chaud froid entre les deux
il opposait qu'il ya il est il est
toujours présent bref c'est une personne
unique en son genre moi j'ai pris un
bain et donc du coup c'est quoi c'est
toi qui va régler l'histoire straw poll
fumeurs là et toi alors quand il va nous
tomber dessus comme pour clément tu vas
te laisser fumer
[Musique]
c'est un peu c'est un peu une grosse
scène pour la série une grosse scène
pour mon personnage
[Musique]
découpez pas bien
même ils se retrouvent avec eric et
vibre déjà ça
toi tu dis si elle n'a pas l'habitude de
faire ça j'ai un calibre j'arrive je
remballe chicha pas vu le braque
[Musique]
et oui et oui bon il me vengera
personnes j'étais encore été ok j'en ai
des craintes
après pas seulement sur les bras 4
une amie sort d'un programme ça fait
déjà un an que ce drame est décédé le
personnage on grandit on voit
directement saison 2 que il porte ce
drame
c'est peut-être la trajectoire de
william qui est la plus impressionnante
de la série parce que il a même une
transformation physique il est beaucoup
plus étoffé sur cette saison deux en
saison une c'est un petit livreur de
sushi est un peu timide qui va
s'improviser
manager et en saison 2 on est sur un mec
charismatique qui va à prendre les rênes
d'un label de musique et qui va devoir
affronter plein de choses qu'ils
n'osaient pas affrontés avant l arrêt
des parlements dans tout ce que j'ai
tout le temps en herbe
qu'est ce que tu vas pas un mois
soit rajouté des embrouilles c'est ça
c'est pas bon pour ton business bon
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur en fait à
ce moment là dans une hes donc au début
on ne cherche pas mal de rappeurs qui ne
faut pas forcément la faire en vrai ce
qui met d'accord c'est les jumeaux
et c'est une galère ces deux là ne
renouerait répond plus
chaude à les jumeaux cet excellent même
en au frisson
et niño on termine marque derrière on
termine rose on termine kim cao termine
carisport termine booba on termine et
pour un clip j'ai une baie vitrée avec
un quad frère va leur montrer
son couple
c'est réglé il ya brahim et saïdou qui
vont se laisser convaincre par inès
engagé une femme pour la première
signature du label apache musique
donc voilà l'idée j'ai retrouvé le seul
talent que j'ai vraiment regretté ne pas
avoir signé à l'époque et je me suis dit
que ce serait parfait pour nous
attend mais il ne sait ni moi je suis
assez réticent au début sur le fait de
prendre une femme et quand j'écoute les
premières phrases qui sortent de sa
bouche je suis je suis totalement choqué
j'ai qu'une envie de travailler quelle
vie
saïdou c'est pas quelqu'un qui avait un
rôle facile il a presque le rôle du mec
un peu chiant un peu moralisateur et je
voir cet acteur changé sous nos yeux
évoluer devenir charismatique devenir
sûr de lui et la preuve qu'il est un
grand comédien je suis très fier de lui
et je suis aussi très fier de ne pas
m'être trompé
[Musique]
original et qui s'est massé laetitia car
femme dont l'âge et 27 on bat comme je
le dis dans mes textes je viens de nulle
part et d'ailleurs de nulle part et
partout j'ai grandi à paris j'ai fait
beaucoup de peine mike j'ai toujours
aimé le rap je fais de la scène j'ai
fait du théâtre s'appelle du salon c'est
une pièce vous jouera pour aussi
l'interprète où je me dévoile aussi un
petit peu comme dans chacun des projets
il y a dans la team validé et plein de
gens plein dead plein de consultants il
ya évidemment toute une équipe technique
toute une équipe d'auteurs tout de
production et puis il ya les petits
satellites qui tourne autour du projet
validé qui sont d'une aide précieuse
dans ton tous ces satellites qui tourne
autour de la série il ya un mec qui
s'appelle screech qui est un célèbre
clippers du rap français et qui depuis
la saison unis il me parlait déjà d'une
film dit il me disait si un jour tu
cherches une fille qui rappe j'en
connais une incroyable j'ai pris mon
temps
on
[Musique]
n'a pas échappé au casting on a vu plein
de filles des filles super mais
incontestablement laëtitia était au
dessus tout je vois cette fille qui
rappe parfaitement bien qu'ils jouent
parfaitement bien et qui porte en elle
un charisme un vécu écorchée vive
de quoi jeter a expliqué me dis qu'on
prend un air je me dis dépend
la qualité principale qu'on cherchait
pour le personnage de l'alfa c'est
d'avoir un super un peu tard on par
cette entente
alors laetitia
non seulement elle avait cette qualité
d'être une bonne rappeuse où on a tout
de suite vu dès le premier casting qu'en
plus elle avait la capacité d'être une
excellente comédienne je suis tombée
enceinte
sans rien changer
la quittes chien de frappe sauf que le
truc c'est que c'était plus seulement ma
vie à moi quitte anges
mais en sort il a frappé trop fort je
suis rentré dans la salle de bain je me
suis renfermé j'ai poussé les meubles
contre la porte et j'ai appelé les keufs
pour leur dire que mon bébé mon on
allait mourir
c'est quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
sensible qui a une capacité incroyable à
rentrer en connexion avec ses émotions
il dit tant que six mois six mois je
perds mon fils tout ce que je vais faire
dans ma vie d'après c'est m'assurer que
le king est grandissant sa mère tu as
compris qui est extrêmement généreuse
qui donne beaucoup à la caméra ses
partenaires en mettait en scène
c'est un luxe de travailler avec
quelqu'un comme ça c'est un luxe
quand j'annonce à laëtitia
quel rôle la première réaction des titia
c'est de me dire je vais tourner avec
sabrina ouazani
[Musique]
thomas
il ya un truc
d'identification tu vois tu comprends
que
laëtitia probablement
s'identifier beaucoup plus à sabrina
ouazani qu'à une autre actrice et c'est
cool ça veut dire que
sabrina a validé les titien
[Musique]
oui effectivement il y avait un truc que
je reconnaissais chez elle qui me
faisait penser à moi il ya
j'ai commencé à 19 ans
et à 19 ans donc à la fois d'une sorte
de de candeur et
d'innocence et de déu qui brille de
découvrir les camarades de découvrir sa
place sur le plateau et voilà et
l'attention qu'on te porte et en même
temps d'avoir autant de responsabilités
[Musique]
il ya quelque chose qui me touche
énormément chez elle et puis ensuite je
suis vraiment une très très belle
sabrina pour la première fois voilà c
c'est une fierté immense c'est
je mets du temps parce que ça m'émeut
s'est passé c'est incroyable c'est une
femme kim pour moi me ressemble en tout
cas dans ses films auparavant dans sa
carrière auparavant m'a beaucoup fait
croire que je c'était possible aussi
pour moi
ça a été a été très très émouvant et
puis c'est surtout aussi au delà de
sabrina l'actrice est aussi l'humain
derrière et l'humain derrière
j'étais j'étais tellement contente
que ce soit exactement ce que j'avais
pensé quoi
il ya une belle histoire entre inès est
l'alpha comme il ya une belle histoire
dans la vie entre sabrina et laeticia
qui naissent et là est la deuxième
héroïne finalement de cette saison
puisque c'est elle qui arrive avec la
bonne idée c'est elle qui va réussir à
les convaincre désolé naissant mais pour
nous c'est trop risqué c'est elle qui va
les rendre un peu plus courageux garde
là si à l'avenir tu devais un peu plus
ouvert d'esprit
c'est elle qui va réussir à convaincre
elle aussi
gb vitesse 4 10 alors quand les
noms je serai pas non je sais pas
pourquoi je sens qu'elle a envie d'y
aller mais un truc qui coince
inès faut que tu lui parles williams
quand je t'ai dit que je m'occupais plus
des rappeurs c'est inclut aussi le
rappeuse je te demande juste de lui
parler
d'essayer de comprendre le problème à
toi te fera confiance
oh
l'enjeu de cette scène aujourd'hui
c'était bien évidemment de convaincre
sarah est l'alpha notre job d'agonistes
revenir dans ce qu'elle aime dans ce qui
est pour moi essentiel indispensable à
sa vie c'est à dire la musique écoute tu
fais comme tu veux sera mais moi je
prenais se gagne et je sais que tu as
fait pour ça ce qui avait de beau c'est
que c'était une vraie scène entre femmes
avec beaucoup de
moment les yeux dans les yeux j'étais
contente que l'on puisse parler d'un
rapport très très bienveillant parce
qu'on est sans cesse aussi en train de
parler parfois des femmes qui se tirent
dans les pattes qui se jalousent et là
au contraire au inès elle est là pour
mettre en valeur et pour mettre dans un
écrin ce diamant brut à mon habitude
tutoriel laisser une chance aux garçons
tout montrer ce qu'ils veulent faire et
moins tu as ma parole de faim que c'est
pas des voyous voilà ça ça chamboule
tout
elle a beaucoup d'espoir mais elle est
perdue en fait elle s'est elle se dit
non je voudrais pas encore me refaire à
voir je veux pas encore retombée et
remettre des surette rails vincent elle
peut-être qu'il y aurait jamais eu ce
contact ou en tout cas cette cette
confiance
à l'abs en fait d'avoir confiance dans
l'alpha
c'est certes on sache que ce serait un
honneur pour moi data manager
[Musique]
vous montrez genre hyper active
impressionné le c'est quoi ce que thomas
jane il s'appelle justement rencontre
pour détendre l'ambiance pour les mettre
à l'aise là soit pas chaud musique qui
est donc dans l'épisode 1 c'est un
moment extrêmement important de la
saison
c'est le moment où il va découvrir que
cette petite meuf qu'on suit depuis le
début de l'épisode est en fait une
artiste qui a quelque chose à dire
qui s'ignorent peut-être d'ailleurs je
pense que dans cette scène elle découvre
qu'elle est une artiste elle découvre
qu'elle a besoin d'être sur scène quant
à l'arrivée qu'elle voit que ya autant
de personnes autant de gens à qui elle
peut dire elle peut montrer et là c'est
impossible qui nous demande et c est pas
quelqu un qui était chaud pour la
recherche et trucks france par jour ça
va j'ai assez donné moi c'est bon leurs
femmes
qu'on ne peut pas casser à la presse
elle pense à cet instant et à cet
instant là c est mature
ayant raté pas une deuxième chance
peut-être que la troisième fois ils me
diront pas aller à lille alpha aller
c'est le dernier régime
d'alpha seront peut-être que c'est une
drogue ça lui avait tellement manqué
c'est ce qu'elle aime c'est tout ce
qu'elle sait faire il est râpeux ça ça
lui brûle à l'intérieur
met en cause un morceau nous vraiment on
pourrait dire que c'est toute la vie et
la présentation de l'alfa plus début de
son enfance son parcours ses peurs ses
peines à anne elle commence comme ça
chaque fois je me suis refait jamais à
genoux toujours prête à pousser ou des
timbales et c'est un moment miroir avec
ce que atik apache à faire en saison une
au moment où ira prison pour mineurs
dans le studio de fret de skype et là il
fallait aussi que laetitia nous envoie
une grosse performance est là
là je leur fais un texte qui qui est
normalement met tout le monde d'accord
jeudi la
compagnie qué juste un micro quoi ton
équipe tu n'y es pas pratiqué monsieur
passion mais qui va non pour retourner
la taille est mangé le rabot général aux
malades du lapacca médical un concert
dans la série mon on a le plaisir de
découper qui fait mouche amateur
d'europe c'est une bête de rappeuse de
cas chaque moment
sites
géologiques
là c'est la première fois que je la
voyais sur scène s'éclater ce envoyer du
lourd
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
je crois que cette saison a de plus que
la première saison c'est qu'elle est
plus sombre beaucoup de gens se sont dit
ça va être une femme l'héroïne ça va
donc être peut-être plus léger alors
qu'en fait les intrigues sont plus durs
que j'ai dit que ça m'intéressait pas
mais c'est quoi le problème écoute vous
dire l'europe j'ai déjà donné c'est plus
pour moi le fait d'être femme rappeuse
mais femme maman rappeuse
qu'est ce que ça implique tout ça quel
est son rapport aux hommes on m'a
fasciné tout de suite
sa façon des de parler de bouger
moi je t'aime qui tenait de la thèse
j'avais plus de familles
et les bahima choisi moi c'est une femme
qui a accepté à un moment d'être soumise
parce qu'elle pensait que c'était son
rôle et que c'était la seule façon
d'exister et elle a rencontré un homme
qui la fascine et qu'elle admirait
énormément sauf que cette personne était
malveillantes et l'a menacé de me tuer
si je portais et là commence à me
frapper
le pire c'est que je pense que tu es
coupable
on va voir aussi au final qu'elle veut
pas être retrouvé que elle est menacée
toi tu me prends moi libertés publiques
ma carrière tu gâches ma vie et tu crois
que je vais te laisser mon fils l'alfa
est notre héroïne et saïd taghmaoui qui
jouent leur de nasser et son grand
méchant donc c'est le grand méchant de
notre intrigue principale ce fils de
[ __ ] là c'est un très grand l'islam donc
on est pas mais jamais les yeux
qu'est
super content de faire partie de cette
aventure
ça fait tellement changé pas travailler
en france je suis déclenché alerte
enlèvement toi tu peux trouver la faille
au jeu mais bref sur la tête du petit je
mens maigrir
il apporte quelque chose de
d'incontestables en termes de puissance
de jeu
2-2 danger sur le personnage de l'alfa
vous là vous voulez unique et son clip
moi je vais l'unique et sa vie
j'ai repris l'entraînement très
sérieusement par rapport au personnage
que ça correspond aux personnages
amusants
tu me crois toi avoir saïd alors qu'il
n'a pas tourné en france depuis très
longtemps alors qu'on est en plein dans
les anniversaires le 25e anniversaire de
la haine
c'est un peu étrange en même temps ça
fait super plaisir parce que je le fais
avec des gens qui viennent d'où je viens
et qui bâille mai on est en famille
passe
il a commencé la balayette
et quand l'un comme dans l'autre
[Applaudissements]
non
donc c'était quand même un kif énorme
d'avoir cet avis sur le projet ça nous
permettait aussi de grade et un petit
peu cette saison avec des nouveautés
dont il fait partie grandement
j'ai décidé de le faire bon un peu en
vue du grand frère alors donné un peu de
force dans le sens où c'est la même
racine là même la même énergie
le personnage de la femme c'est une
guerrière qui sinon tu couches a même
laissé faire pas de concession à
prisonniers fait devenir intouchable au
début de la saison elle subit ce qui lui
arrive et il ya un moment donné où
elle subit plus je prends plus les coûts
sans réagir c'est fini tout ça je veux
plus jamais peur de rien c'est moi elle
décide d'arrêter elle décide de 2 se
dévoile et elle se rend compte que son
passé c'est pas à elle de le subir tout
seul et que c'est pas de sa faute
[Musique]
ce qui m'intéressait dans le fait de
traiter du parcours d'une femme dans
cette saison 2 c'est les difficultés que
ça représente d'être une femme dans ce
milieu du rap excuse moi je te poser
juste une petite question serait prête à
arrêter là tu travailles dans la musique
tu sais bien que les gens ne veulent pas
d'une oeuvre qui ravale là quand on se
parle d'une fille qui doit regrouper
comme un mec là c'est plus compliqué là
on est confronté à la réalité des
chiffres qui fait que ça marche - où ça
marche pas du tout et ça c'était
intéressant de le traiter vous devez
vous arrêter de faire des aveugles en
fait une meuf qui veut juste faire du
rap ça va pas le faire et si en plus ça
m'écoute pas assez sur l'espace sera un
poil je vous garantis c'est un milieu
machiste non j'ai envie de te dire parce
que ce qu'on oublie souvent c'est que
derrière les rappeurs a souvent des
femmes qu'elles soient directrice
artistique patronne de la belle
aujourd'hui à quessoy manager il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes qui ont tour
des rappeurs et ça c'est important et on
ne dit pas assez grand qu'avec signe un
contrat qui faisait le contrôle
artistique de toute neuve moi j'ai rien
à voir son contrat moi donc j'ai pas les
m'afficher pour lui faire plaisir mais
je te laisse gérer ça parce que ça me
semble finir beaucoup nana beaucoup
d'artistes qui s'y sont tentés qui s'y
sont essayés il y en ad pas mal et on a
des super je pense que
je pense qu'il ya une sorte d'entre deux
aussi qu'on a essayé de trouver dont on
parle en dents dans cette saison
toujours à essayer de police et lisser
l'image de la femme est toujours essayé
de dire ok mais faut que tu danses
méchante un petit peu ne faut pas que tu
sois trop trash parentaux foutu sur les
peaux sexy pour contre garde pour qu'on
a envie de t'ecouter un petit peu plus
alors que pour moi la question n'est pas
là
non non
[Musique]
non non sinon tu peux couper ça te plaît
et ce style là ça va pas le faire alors
on saison une j'avais un personnage un
peu ambigu qui jouait entre apache et ma
star sur cette saison de son ambiguïté
j'ai essayé avec les auteurs de la
placer sur
ok vous voulez signer une fille dans le
rap moi je sais que ça marche pas bien
ça marche pas du tout les filles dans le
rap c'est vrai rabais mais maintenant je
vais parler clairement moi j'aurais
voulu sortir mes meilleures preuves toi
tu apprends à lui payer tout le
marketing que tu veux
la réalité c'est qu'il me super forte à
vendre à toujours moins qu'un mec moyens
c'est comme ça c'est game bah ouais et
james alors
mais à bahreïn
au départ je suis pas du tout dans le
mood de williams et brahim j'ai pas
envie de lui donnais mes meilleurs prod
j'ai envie de lui faire faire de la
zumba lui faire faire de la faire
chanter j'ai pas envie car rap parce que
je suis convaincu qu une meuf qui rappe
ça marchera moi tu veux que je fasse
poletti bas quelque chose de
l'entraînement d'un peu plus club quoi
tu vois que je chante en fait
donc j'incarne dans cette saison 2 la
mauvaise morale celle d'une partie du
rap game et une partie du public qui se
dit la flemme défi qui rappelons-le a
pas envie de voir des films qui rappe je
pense que vous dire qu'il n'a pas osé te
le dire donc je vais faire moi
ce que tu as envie de faire toi c'est
pas une bonne idée
vas-y du monde qu'est ce qui serait
mieux pour moi de changer de style
d'ouvrir un truc plus pop plus actuelle
plus féminin quoi voilà ce que dj snow
doit doit jouer pendant toute cette
première partie jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
rendent compte que cette nana est
bluffante et et qu'elle lui le quai le
convaincre qu'ils se trompent
je pense que c'est saison clé clairement
au coeur des problématiques de société
aujourd'hui puisque ça raconte comment
une femme peut être libre et
indépendante dans un milieu qui n'est
pas forcément bienveillants à son égard
on voit pas beaucoup de mal dans les
open mic par exemple elles ont peur de
participer tu crois bas j'avoue je sais
pas la porte parole des rappeuses de
france mais moi j'ai pas peur en tout
cas pas c'est un milieu très masculin
comment l'expliquer je pense qu'avant
tout les femmes peut-être pas forcément
envie d'entrer dans cette compétition
parce que c'est un milieu très
compétitif qui peut être très blessant
très dur la vérité c'est que quand on n
9 bat faut sortir des morceaux deux fois
plus lourd et et voilà il met tout le
monde d'accord quoi et c'est vrai que
celles qui vont celle qui rentrent
dedans il ya souvent une fêlure souvent
des choses qui fait qu'à un moment cette
pousse aussi à rentrer dans ce milieu
toi tu irais tranquille te frotter à des
mecs mais courneuve tu m'emmènes en
battle givet et puis et puis je suis sûr
y en a je peux les étendre là en train
de tourner
non
c'était plutôt pas mal du tout on a avec
nous les spécialistes français de
l'organisation jura pro gamers avec des
champions du monde de bakker après
avoir une taille je vide mes potes je
t'envoie à l'hôpital tu vas t'en dormir
dans les bras devant villes en europe
containers cette discipline qui à la
base vient des états unis c'est à
capella c est la prestance scénique et
la qualité d'écriture la qualité des
punchline et la qualité à pouvoir
répondre aussi sur le moment c'est
vraiment une discipline à part entière
le type auteurs j'ai un couple un petit
fou un petit coup
alors validé ne pas mettre cette
dimension là ça serait pas montré le rap
dans son intégralité
vous comprendre que tu as une foule
quant à des gens qui sont là que pour
entre guillemets voir du sang exactement
comme un vrai match de boxe tu peux
écrire des choses qui peuvent paraître
lourd au papier mais sur le moment si ça
fait pas mouche tu rates ton coup elle
accepté l'invitation
musique fête tombe à simon venu pour la
porte
[Applaudissements]
afful les deux fausses infos complètes a
l'impression de monter sur le ring pour
laetitia c'était pas évident pour elle
de déjà sur un premier tournage j'ai eu
le rôle principal et tu dois faire un
rap contenders
sortez à mr
pas vendre un coach dit tu es une
caillera
becker avait pas besoin d'une mise à
jour genre à faire besoin d'une mise à
jour d'aucune salle
moi en tant que les ti qui suit rappeuse
à la base j'ai fait beaucoup de peine
mike mais je suis pas beaucoup dans la
battle c'est pas vraiment des liens donc
du coup et c'était une première aventure
mais c'était intense d'enfants at on vu
le
jour en
cours
il y avait beaucoup de détermination il
fallait de tenir le coup et et j'étais
très j'étais très fier de l'alpha et el
al et yossi est elle la muscu et
esquives
[Applaudissements]
et c'est une scène qui est très
important pour nous aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle va déclencher des choses très
graves pour la suite de l'intrigué j'ai
du respect et je dis pas tu as l'air et
pourrait croire je suis ton baril
[Applaudissements]
d'abord deux jours je peux te dire que
quand tu vois les quelques vidéos de rap
contenders sur lesquels des femmes se
font laminer avec et punchline ultra
misogyne et ultra déplacer ultra
vulgaire ah oui tu comprends à quel
point il ya peu de nanas dans ce genre
d'événement
c'est un peu le mot frère
grosse performance de rachid gallas qui
joue le rôle de yamar qui est absolument
insupportable et qui est donc parfait
dans ce rôle et encore plus dans cette
scène moi je suis donc à la base du cou
j'avais jusqu'à ce prix là un peu de
compétition rentrer dans un truc face à
face avec son adversaire et c'est un peu
ça que j'essaie de reproduire quoi ce
moment là tu as vu
il raconte en dire c'est quelque chose
que je regarde depuis collège lycée je
crois que je commence à regarder j'ai
toujours écouté durable j'ai toujours
écrit des petits textes une fois que
j'ai reçu le texte je les réécrire un
petit peu ma manière et leur fragile et
coécrit avec un os moussa j'ai enlevé
des choses on est rajouté
de la est sorti le morceau et des terres
on voit dans l'épisode 5 ça court
ça morceaux très brutal très frontal ça
rend directement dans le vif du sujet
quand est-ce que tu attaques ont fait
l'histoire enfin disons c'est à cause de
moi non papa est en prison
en fait y avoir il n'a pas vraiment le
même but que tous les m6 qui vont
raconter leurs ce qu'on en arrive là il
ya marie vient juste pour la détruire et
pour donner des gros dossiers sur elle
vient pas pour gagner pour amuser la
galerie mais la carrière d'un groupe et
qui est ma star
il vient vraiment pour la piéger sortir
des gros dos sur et le quoi et vraiment
il faut l'éteindre j'ai pas encore la
gestion très peu le savent mais tu as
fait la pire traces la sélection était
encore 4e mais mon fils voulait par
dessus tout temps le saint denis
l'alfa tu apprends
que yamar
est là pour elle en fait
mais voit ses casses toi c'est du passé
le beau jour de repos mexes
dans ça parle de son fils où ça parle
vraiment de son passé et l'a donc du
coup il à elle elle s'en va
elle lâche le micro elle produit total
panique et donc c'est quelque chose de
très dur pour elle
c'est un moment de la ce en quoi c'est
un très bon épisode l'épisode 5 et ce
clip d'épisodes sens écrit absolument
terrifiant et à lui tout seul il il
rassemble vraiment ce qu'on avait envie
de raconter sur voila quoi ça peut
ressembler les difficultés d'être une
femme parmi eux durable quand tu veux
vraiment aller se frotter sur le terrain
des mecs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on masta enfin la saison 2 il est dans
une période de transition et il sort son
premier film s'appelle libérables un
film d'action ou joie cup un peu tu vois
un truc un truc un peu carré juste une
petite seconde et je voulais te
féliciter j'ai adoré ce que tu as il est
dans une période de doute justement qui
arriva souvent des personnes qui sont au
top depuis un certain moment avec des
remords qui assure la mort d'apache le
fait que carnage et sur ses côtes ils
pensent que ok la salle en conversion et
puis au dernier moment tout s'écrouler
c'est un peu le karma qui lui tombe
dessus comme
ma star va nous permettre d'incarner la
descente d'un rappeur ça aussi c'est
fascinant a raconté on prend en masse
tard en saison une que j'ai imaginé
comme un rappeur très en place un
rappeur a dû les
rapports avec plusieurs disques d'or une
grande carrière et puis il fallait qu'on
raconte aussi ce qui se passe quand ça
retombe donc le personnage de ma star
nous permet de raconter que le rap il ya
des hauts et des bas quand il ya débat
ils peuvent être très douloureux très
compliqué surtout quand on a fait des
mauvais choix ma star a fait les mauvais
choix
il va aller voir up pouvoir faire que
rohff instant qu'on entre élus et
carnage et il se dit bon il est obligé
d'accepter de faire un album commun avec
lui sauf que mme ashton dans une phase
descendante et du coup
alcool il est un peu mal en point dans
qu'il en studio et puis ça se passe pas
très bien être qui peut l'ennemi finie
la rigolade le songe depuis tard je
crois c'est mieux qu'on arrête là pour
aujourd'hui
je te casse la croûte rohff qui vient et
puis moi qui parle mal à rome là c'est
bien parce que vous proposez
pour la seule chose qui va démarrer
c'est à charest
pas sympa nos plateaux vous étonner là
c'est la première fois que c'est vrai ça
toi en disant à tourtemagne pas tari et
y va franchement ça provoque qui
l'empêché de se lever je vois et 1 seule
chose que tu as démarré tôt c'est à
charritte invasif en tête chez toi ça
prouve en
personne chez moi tu veux faire mal à
tout de suite sorte de ses gonds et me
dit bob m'a dit c'est fini des bretons
avec avec ton arrête la collaboration et
c est plus d'albums terminée allez
dégage de marie prends tes affaires
quand fu est c'est le moment sans que ma
star se rend compte qu'en fait ils en
train de tout perdre puis rien ne marche
là y'a plus d'échappatoire
pour cette bas mais il ya encore plus
bas
tu as voulu faire affaire avec lui sans
passer par mois
lui c'est la rue c'est pas le rap
maintenant tu es tout seul
et tu vas te débrouiller comme avant
enfin carnage de la été déposé c'est que
des soucier un des soucis un
carnage qui est né par le rappeur bosch
maintenant on peut dire le rappeur
embauches au moment où on a commencé les
on ne savait pas qui c'était maintenant
ils savent tous ce
qui est moche et qui est carnage mais
bof ça aussi été un événement incroyable
les gens ont découvert ce personnage de
carnage et mais j'ai tellement de gens
même métier du cinéma qui m'ont appelé
en disant où est ce que tu as trouvé ce
mec il est incroyable il me fait peur
en saison 2 carnage arrive plus à nez
avec jamais il a des comptes à régler et
il n'est pas du genre très diplomate
carnage
ont deux secondes avant lui annoncer la
roumanie
l'éminent côté crois
que tu es sont prêts
qui font le temps qu'eux mêmes
spectateurs vous disent qu'est-ce qui va
dire parce que à ce moment là il n'y a
pas que brain et les spectateurs qui est
depuis le début on a su le faire par ces
yamamay comme une gens qui ont des
doutes du mar
qui font ce moment prenons deux secondes
qu'est ce qui va lui balancer quand mon
bateau et d'une
annonce parue
tu m'aimes dans le comment
de plus début je dis que c'est la main
écoute moi bien ses filets de me faire
perdre mon temps échecs et les play off
et c'est qui ce cache comme une petite
[ __ ] donc maintenant je veux aller dire
qu'il ait à thomas 18 ans qu'on me
ramener mont lozère la chicha d'ousmane
sa moment très important dans quoi je
les fais à fond et j'étais pas mal joué
sinon je fume tous un par un
comme je fumais en page
vous lire mais il pensait que c'était a
marre de bosses qui avait tué son ami
samir a partout redoux se rend compte
que ces carnages et hank jones et
tombèrent des tâches propres à une
charge carrelage
aux masters je te parle pourquoi je le
cherche parce qu'il a découvert que
c'est duke l'actu pop il ya quelque
chose que j'ai appris avec la série qui
est fantastique c'est de tizé les gens
c'est tu vois c'est un truc fantastique
ça est
belle je voulais quand même laissé des
pistes de réflexion pour les gens
besser c'est à dire que
j'ai pas cherché à le cacher j'ai pris
le vrai comédien qui est un casque c'est
sa vraie moto qu'il a toute la série qui
l'a même sur la deuxième saison il
arrive avec son t max et c'est lui qui
descend et que dire
voilà tu attends un petit peu j'attends
un petit peu tu ne regardes et bintou
tiers
il s'est vendu plus de ça
le problème quand tu écris d'un
personnage comme celui de carnage qui
est
extrêmement violent
et à un moment où il va lui arriver des
problèmes c'est sûr
parce que tu lui fait faire des choses
qui vont tellement loin que
tu as tout fait ou d'un moment qu'est ce
qui va faire de plus après tu vois ce
que je dit il et il est tellement dur
tellement violent gêné ce serait par
ailleurs chicha
ça nous tire sur
je vais sauver ces jeunes au petit louis
et où je tire sur carrelage ma star
arrive et un point de non retour tu le
seul moyen de régler pas dire le mal par
le mal est de passer à l'acte je prends
des armées puis suivent et puis voilà
on va regarder le train est alors à la
danse est saine
donc là je la vois pas la marque
beaucoup d'acteurs à me réjouir ce genre
de scène justement tu pues de quelqu'un
avec tout ce que ça implique
tout entre deux de désarroi de deux
d'orgueil en fait parce que c'est quand
même ma star c'est quoi ça
cette scène là j'ai eu du mal à la
tournée ça m'a énervé thème faire fumer
et au moins dix fois d'affilée comme ça
c'était dur il s'appelait aussi signé la
fin de carnage mais on sait pas car
nager les carnages et l'increvable je
sais comment c'est en réalité un
il y en a on était sûrs qu'ils étaient
morts
et finalement ils sont pas morts et puis
on a on était sûrs qu'ils n'étaient pas
morts et puis son mari
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout
d'abord david chez davidian toujours là
toujours présent si après david ya pas
validé j'ai commencé moi je vais
commencer à écouter du rap en 1988 je me
suis construit avec j'ai mes souvenirs
avec j'ai commencé en écoutant
des assassins
aujourd'hui j'écoute je me gausse et
pénales on retrouve sur le ferry comme
en saison une
mais c'est cool ça est une bonne nuit ça
fait longtemps que je travaille dans le
cinéma ça fait pas très longtemps je
suis réalisateur mme hermange et
travailler sur pas mal des clips
notamment le clip de pour ceux enfin moi
je travaille pas marrer conques rage
mais à l'époque frank qui étaient avec
nous aussi à cette époque là on était
tous dans cette même bande
oui mais je vais raconter la peur dans
les yeux du comédien raconte
diane était mon premier insistant sur
mon premier film qui étaient les
cailleras il ya dix ans
c'est moche mariage
à
partir du moment où j'ai pris la
décision de jouer dans validé je savais
que j'allais avoir besoin d'être aidé à
la mise en scène tout simplement parce
que quand je suis en train de jouer ya
bien quelqu'un me dirige
j'ai appelé david en lui disant écoute
sur cette première saison je te propose
deux premiers assistants sur les
épisodes que je vais réaliser et puis
étant parfois devenir réalisateur
maintenant et je te laisse réalisé des
épisodes de la série
à tel point que sur cette saison 2 j'ai
décidé de lui laisser la majorité des
épisodes donc la saison 2 de valider et
en majeure partie réalisé par david
devenu évidemment un allié indispensable
au bon fonctionnement de cette série et
puis surtout à la qualité artistique de
cette série c'est un grand cinéphile
très bon technicien quelqu'un qui a des
tas d'idées mises en scène des tas
d'idées de films inc
probablement puisque moi-même
l'idée c'est quand même d'encre et
profondément cette série dans la réalité
que ce soit une série de son temps qui
parle des gens d'aujourd'hui avec les
gens d'aujourd'hui pour les gens
d'aujourd'hui ont travaillé beaucoup de
comédiens qui sont des jeunes comédiens
on n'avait pas envie de les mettre dans
un dispositif contraignant de cinéma qui
dès empêcherait d'exprimer leur naturel
c'est ça qui nous intéressait c'est ça
qu'on allait chercher ses n'invite pour
l'avant première de son film ce soir à
des grosses têtes ce serait bien que ce
soit la première chose c'était d'avoir
un dispositif de tournage assez simple
qui permettait de tourner un peu dans la
longueur pour garder les émotions pour
les comédiens le plus possible
bon
à côté
et
si un mot
concernant
les serments pas coller et en même temps
qui permet aussi une rapidité
d'exécution qui fait qu' on consacre
plus de temps dans une journée de
tournage à travailler la comédie qu'à
travailler la technique
cette détermination
en permanence et une détermination pour
réussir mon corps s'accrochant danse est
donc clairement il a été décidé dès le
début d'une utiliser aucune machinerie
de filmer cette série entièrement à
l'épaule
tu vois que c'était pas compliqué
ce qui a contribué à l'image de marque
de la série il ya ces lumières pour
lequel j'étais m'inspirer de gomorra
l'idée c'était de mettre en place des
codes couleur différent pour ce qui est
donc en saison 1 c'était un peu
paris banlieue la saison 2 on a décidé
de faire plutôt un truc sur tout ce qui
est la musique et tout ce qui est un peu
la voyoucratie
[Musique]
le rap contenders qui est clairement une
séquence qui est dans lequel on a voulu
quand même raconté le côté underground
du rap donc un truc un peu enfermé un
peu oppressant et c'est clair que
jusqu'ici passe pour nous c'était que
l'endroit où la voyoucratie rencontre le
show business et où elle prend le dessus
donc dans cette séquence là on a mis du
vert et du jaune qui était un peu nos
séquences de voyoucratie donc on a mis
un peu des tâches avec des néons par-ci
par-là de vert de jaune puis ya cette
signature qui est le plan aux drones qui
permet de commencer la saison on avait
ce plan aux drones en pivot inversée qui
commençait là l'épisode 1 de la saison
une
pour la saison 2 je voulais quelque
chose d'un peu plus impressionnant qu'on
aille encore un petit peu plus loin dans
cette technique du drone avec ce plan
qui part du haut de la cité pour aller
jusque dans l'appartement pour découvrir
la fin et puis rentrer dans cette télé
dans lequel on découvre que là ya plus
de doute apache est mort donc ce plan au
delà d'être esthétique nous raconte des
choses et effectivement ça dit un peu la
marque de fabrique de cette série de
commencer par un plan drôle qu'ils
soient à chaque fois un peu pensé un peu
impressionnant
[Musique]
les clins d'oeil à la n y en avait déjà
dans la première saison pour les grands
spécialistes et puis sur la saison 2 bat
d'abord il ya saïd taghmaoui
action
et puis pour les vrais spécialistes
dans la chicha qui devient la chicha de
carnage
le gros panneau publicitaire qui a
devant la chicha il y a écrit le monde
est à nous mais c'est vraiment la fiche
de line c'est à dire c'est le monde est
à vous avec rayé de saïd qui écrit un n
à la place du v
la scène hip hop à marseille est
absolument inévitable allez allez allez
grande halle talentueuse elle est belle
marseille aussi c'est notre miami
français a filmé ses fantastiques les
lumières sont fantastiques les décors
sont fantastiques moi j'y ai pris goût
on alentours des taxis
et dès la première saison de valider je
voulais absolument qu'on fasse
participer marseille que marseille fasse
partie de ce projet cherche qu est
intégrée du casting marseille est
enterré des rappeurs mort s'est
rendu à savoir
chez moi et une du pourquoi je veux
savoir
évidemment que on a été très bien
accueilli là bas
et une confrontation
grave et après rod inquiète
alors c'est quand même trente petites
salles on peut noter vos murder que
j'attendais depuis longtemps l'ayant
écrit c'est pas les immigrés qu'elle
fasse à à coffre on se casse le rappeur
marseillais qui pour la petite histoire
sont du même quartier et c'est dans ce
quartier contournent cette scène en ce
moment par faire une heure de sommeil
peut en douter avant ça je voudrais bien
ton problème à mars c'est un quartier
dans lequel ils ont grandi tous les deux
c'est pour ce genre de moments qu'on
fait valider ou 10 insee pour avoir à
diriger des rappeurs des rappeurs de ce
niveau là
c'était une volonté depuis le début de
dire valider ce n'est pas une série de
parisiens validé c'est la première série
qui parle du milieu du rap en france
actuelle est donc ça doit pas être une
série parisienne c'est une série
nationale qui parlent de notre culture
française de la musique urbaine
[Musique]
moi c'est fifo photographe et directeur
artistique depuis plus de quinze ans
entre autres dans le milieu urbain le
rap on connaît surtout sur mon travail
sur les pochettes de beaucoup d'artistes
succès un milieu assez petit là je me
retrouve une évolution d'avoir
pratiquement bosse avec tout le monde
essentiellement la scène parisienne à la
base maintenant c'est fait quelque temps
que je travaille beaucoup avec les
marseillais aux six voix douce autres
anneaux et sur paris sur les plus
anciens on peut parler de secteur à pacy
doc gynéco et aujourd'hui tu as toute la
nouvelle génération se rappelle la
dreale aussi donc nouveaux artistes
comme gazeau les artistes plus confirmés
comme ligne eaux et la boue
matusz c'est la mise en scène c'est
créer des mises en scène assez hors
normes entre guillemets et qui essaye de
casser un peu les codes des pochettes de
rap de mecs en bas de leur bloc même si
j'aime bien faire ce type de shooting
mais en tout cas dans les pochettes qui
ressortent ces derniers temps c'est
beaucoup de mises en scène où j'aime
bien aussi allié des éléments qui vont
pas forcément ensemble faire une oeuvre
assez fois le quoi voilà on m'a appelé
pour
jouer mon propre rôle qui espèce de mise
en abyme
j'ai capté fotolia pas de soucis kawa
non c'est l'inversé
explique moi ce que tu veux faire j'ai
toujours ce souci du détail qui est
devenu d'ailleurs un challenge dans
cette série qui est toujours de mélanger
la réalité et la fiction est de faire
participer à la série les vrais
protagonistes du vrai milieu du vrai
monde du rap et je prends beaucoup de
plaisir à faire participer aussi des
techniciens des personnalités du monde
du rap alors parfois ça va être un
tourneur photographe réalisateur
aujourd'hui afficheront il ya aussi
screech qui est un célèbre choeur de
deux clips de rap je trouve que c'est ça
qui fait que valider est ancré dans
cette réalité c'est qu'on fait
participer les vraies personnes
taylor
a parlé
et j'ai joué avec rohff ya une scène qui
est très très forte avec rohff
c'est un dieu c'est simple soit sûrs en
jetons câline termine la discussion sont
attachés et assume quand je pense que
c'est possible
h à douala il a énormément aux achats
doisneau madarassou noir
de tourner avec rohff c'est quand même
quelque chose tu vois parce que en
europe fait partie comme ma carrière
comme plein d'autres de ces gens qui ont
fait le rap que moi j'ai grandi avec ses
musiques cancer
sur cette saison de la participation de
rohff était prévu est écrit en amont
parce que il avait déjà fait savoir sur
la saison une qu'il avait envie d'être
dans la saison et puis c'est quelque
chose d'important pour un rappeur
d'aller prendre le risque en fait de
faire un acteur
donc moi je suis très respectueux de
chacun des guest chacun des rappeurs qui
osent venir jouer un rôle même s'ils
jouent leur propre rôle tout ça est
quand même de l'acting et c'est pas
simple c'est pas donné à tout le monde
et puis je suis aussi très reconnaissant
parce qu'ils apportent avec eux à chaque
fois
leur image ils apportent avec eux leur
public et cette série elle elle est
devenue ce qu'elle est en grande partie
grâce à eux pour être très honnête mais
choix sur les guest sont aussi orientés
par le public c'est à dire je cherche à
faire plaisir au public et je me pose la
question de savoir quel rappeur qu'elles
baissent le public aimerait voir et puis
alors il ya ce que j'aimerais avoir qui
sont pas dispo il ya ceux qui semblent
pas de faire l'acteur il ya ceux qui
aimeraient des rôles plus gros et puis
au milieu de toutes ces équations bas on
trouve quelques solutions qui sont les
gaz qui sont dans la série moi en tant
que ça et doux c'est toujours pareil
toujours impressionné cette pas très
longtemps qu'on est dans ce milieu là
donc de voir que non et re principaux
d'une série dans laquelle autour de nous
il ya des gens qu'on a écouté en
grandissant
c'était très très content parce que j'ai
retrouvé une grande amie à moi qui ai
amel bent
j'étais contente de voir voilà hamel qui
qui valide laetitia là à travers cette
petite scène
franchement reste pas parce que tu as
fait hier soir ma soeur vicky fait je
pense que toutes les mains font kiffer
merci merci beaucoup franchement
vraiment à ça me touche et en plus je
suis pas fan bon bah voilà elle
présentera les présentations n ya plus
besoin tout le monde la connaît
maintenant j'ai aussi joué avec dinos
donc ça j'étais contente en fait en tout
cas on s'est croisés pour une petite
scène et aux dinos à écouter ouais je
l'écouté devrait franchement l'occupé
techno je mange une surprise
il y avait pas mal d'artistes toutes les
générations en passant de francs glee
chat gazeaux qui est sorti récemment
pour ceux qui écoutent du rap moi j'ai
vu siffler son basket
il ya une interview que sniper aux purs
et sly père c'est mon enfance il y avait
un parterre incroyable comme d'habitude
en vrai ça devient un peu la marque de
fabrique de valider de ramener des
célébrités qui jouent leur propre rôle
et qui y participent tu l'auras ton buzz
on espère
[Musique]
contre les ti est l'alpha et une
différence dans le rapide à vis de la
douceur on va dire que la fa va cacher
sa douceur vin cacher parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de loups autour d'elle les tirs
les tirs
j'ai peu de raison de me thermique tout
le monde où je ne ferai pas preuve
d'humilité vu qu'ici pas tout le monde
ce père j'ai mis de côté mes sentiments
les modalités ne viens pas me parler de
charité
la plupart des paroles de la halle face
à moi qui les ai écrites près j'ai été
beaucoup en collaboration avec sens
vraiment il m'a beaucoup beaucoup appris
avec lui ça a vraiment beaucoup match
est ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est que ça
rappe brut qui renferme beaucoup
d'émotion si tu veux mon jeu comporte
souvent l'alpha un diamant brut ou faire
attention à le polir pour vraiment
sortir les meilleurs éléments et c'est
ce qui m'a plu à travailler avec elle
parce que c'est une boule d'énergie et
même quand tu la vois quand tu parles
est là toute cette énergie en elle qui
sortent et le challenge était justement
de prendre les bonnes énergies au bon
moment pour bien justement la mettre en
valeur on est en studio et on est parti
de ces textes à elle c'est vraiment un
travail ensemble
ce que j'apporte et c'est est ce que l
avais en tête mais qu'elle n'arrivait
pas forcément en sortir et là quand
arrive un level où justement tu dois
faire comprendre aux gens qui sont
durables et qu'ils ne sont pas durables
à aimer le rap enfin certaine manière
certaines choses qu'il faut faire
ressortir plus que d'autres une question
de timing aussi l'homme de timing
musicale et c'était super intéressante
avec elle
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est chez les fous et
c'est une scène d'un shoot photo un peu
particulier pour des raisons un peu
particulière
[Musique]
jean van hamme est là
pour canapé bleu c'est quelque chose
qu'on a coécrit c'est comme si je
rentrais dans sa tête et je suis me suis
mis à sa place en fait
c'est un moment auquel je tenais
beaucoup je suis complètement à
l'initiative de cette idée j'ai compris
que les auteurs qu'il fallait qu'on
parle de la puissance de la méchanceté
de l'aspect néfastes de la violence des
réseaux sociaux et surtout de cette
triste réalité que un bad buzz est
toujours plus événementielle qui a un
goût de buzz
égard on va pas tarder à faire la photo
donc si on les attend dehors s'il vous
plaît ça serait cool et
on va sur les réseaux sociaux on
cherchait des mauvaises nouvelles on va
on veut voir des gens qui tombent voir
des gens qui se blesse on veut pas voir
des gens qui sont heureux et je voulais
raconter ce que ça pouvait provoquer
chez une nana qui arrive dans ce game
qui avait déjà des réticences à
redevenir un peu ce parce que c'est que
c'est très dur et puis à la ses
casseroles et puis il ya les complexités
de tout ça on fait comme si on t'aime on
fait comme si on a envie d'écouter des
morceaux
mais on va se jeter sur la première bad
news qui qui qui tombe
le talent ça paye plus je fais deux fois
plus de points que tu crois que tu sois
fier fort tu préfères pas compte elle
qui pourra monter le public j'ai dû être
très tête lakes t'explique j'ai voulu
raconter une scène où
notre héroïne aller avec l'aide de
william qui a qu'à l'idée principale
comment ensemble ils vont réussir à
s'associer en une nuit pour faire d'un
bad buzz un goût de buzz comment est-ce
qu'ils vont mettre le nez dans la merde
des gens voilà c'est ça que je voulais
montrer
[Musique]
pourquoi tu la
sors et la recontre si un jour je me
suis fait rosser stromae quand je
travaille les fuites et il ya quelques
années une vidéo de lui complètement
bourré dans les rues de bruxelles ou la
malveillance des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux
se jette sur cette vidéo avec joie
regarde il est bourré regarde c'est la
décadence regarde la honte et que deux
jours après et explique que c'était pour
un clip et c'est un des plus gros
morceau de sa carrière et il a [ __ ]
tout le monde en leur disant regardez
comme vous êtes méchant
[Musique]
peut pas faire une série dans le rap où
on sait que le ya une partie du public
du rap font partie des plus dures des
plus virulents sur les réseaux sociaux
sans qu'on fasse un petit appel de
phares en disant regardez parfois
prenons quelques instants pour se poser
la question du mal que ça fait à la
personne concernée c'est le moment où de
façon le plus évidente dans la série
elle décide de ne plus être victimes et
la façon qu est la réponse est justement
temps victimes qui sont agressés mais
elle reprend les rênes de son destin et
ça je pense que c'est super important
c'est magnifique
dans la trajectoire de ce personnage
summum de la bêtise humaine est
respectée plein d'abonnés alors qu'en
fait tu t'es qu'une merde alors qu'en
fait quelques unes mer sont prêts à
garder tout le sud ça commence à bursa
mandat trop sage ou le juge une bande de
lâches mais je vous rappelle que je suis
la grille j'ai bien compris tu pour
faire le gosse de valère pays les plus à
gauche du coup j'ai de quoi faire réagir
la plèbe le phototype allongée sur un
canapé blanc secteur n'a pas eu assez il
me reste coi dans les chiottes avait pas
encore au top que j'obtiens de terre
cuite ou peu après vers de terre est
devenue un papillon est donc la dernière
séquence des hip hop symphonie c'est le
papillon
[Musique]
c'est magique parce que oui c'est un
morceau très important c'est le morceau
final de l'épisode 9 et c'est vraiment
une délivrance pour elle parce que elle
devient une femme elle s'accomplit en
tant qu rappeuse
c'est un peu une consécration pour elle
et se sont se sont amenés à la liberté
c'est vraiment un morceau à l est de le
voir en symphonie pour elle c'est et 1
c'était une première de jouer avec un
orchestre symphonique
et je trouve forte parce qu'elle a
réussi à s'adapter et sur intrus et en
rap contenders est maintenant en
orchestre symphonique est l'ami du letty
cher dans l'alpha de la foi dans
laëtitia est ce qui fait que ce morceau
il est particulier
tous
plus promnog sûr on dit qu'on a à la
version qui est on à la version vivre là
où ils en ont fait la version
je raconte
ma vie
et que du coup un chef d'orchestre issam
krimi grand chef d'orchestre donc voilà
quarante violons derrière tout plein
d'instruments c'est cette scène elle est
grandiose et pour les rappeurs se ya des
moments où quand tu entends des instrus
ça sort tout seul c'était forcément ça
qui c'était ça
si je suis là ce soir
c'est grâce à williams et brême de
l'apache musique cette france et le
début de la nouvelle vie de la fin merci
mes frères
merci merci c'est grâce à toi tout a
commencé
merci
photo massa on se sait on alliés pas
besoin de parler on se connaît maman
tonk rappeuse tout ce que j'espère c'est
que la visibilité que j'ai eu moins dans
cette série qui parle de rabat ça pourra
donner plein de force à toutes les
autres rappeuse djs non le magicien bon
magicien j'espère qu'on va continuer à
faire de grandes choses ensemble
merci dans la vie mon analyse c'est que
ya une place à prendre il ya une place
pour une femme ou peut-être même dès
lors plusieurs cliques et arriveront et
qui qui raconteront surtout leur
histoire leurs fêlures leurs blessures
et puis qui rentreront là dedans dans la
compétition donc il ya un vrai challenge
et c'est pas fermé il faut leur dire
qu'elles viennent s'ils ont envie de
rappeler il faut pas avoir peur de rap
et
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est une
femme qui rappe merveilleusement bien
qui rappe comme un homme mais à qui on
dit les femmes ça marche pas moi j'ai
décidé de parler d'une femme nora a qui
ont dit tout le temps ça marche pas et
qui elle veut dire vous verrez moi ça va
marcher je suis convaincu d'une chose
aujourd'hui pour qu'on se parle c'est
que ça va marcher pour elle dans la
série mais dans la vraie vie ça va
marcher aussi
mais
j'ai préparé un stade parfait la pelouse
est parfaite le public est là maintenant
il faut qu'elle fasse un grand match
dessus elle m'a déjà fait un grand match
pendant le tournage je sais que cette
saison va marquer les gens parce qu'elle
a envoyé à l'image et puis le reste du
match après il est sans moi mais en tout
cas j'ai bien préparé le terrain foyer
on va de toute manière
[Musique]
au fil de la fille
la nuit dans la nuit là ma limite
[Musique]
moi je pourrais me passer pour
les
ce qui était important sur cette saison
2 c'était que je clôture quelque chose
je n'ai pas encore mon onze par l'idée
de la saison 3 n'est pas question
d'entamer une saison 3 tant que j'ai pas
une idée forte et des convictions de
faire quelque chose de puissant
je peux très bien dire ok moi j'arrête
validé mais je laisse des gens de faire
à ma place
et je vais pas réussi à faire ça
[Musique]